[Music]
mg's back baldwin Shepard look at that
face look at that nose look at that
camera angle this is the saddest party
on the city now this is where we're
trying to kill all of our teammates or
at least as many as we can
in the worst way as possible we've
already done three episodes and
unfortunately this episode probably
won't have a lot of killing but we'll
see we'll see we're hoping we can get to
Morton's death one can hope one can
certainly hope but we figured we'd kick
things off by customizing our armor a
little bit gonna be seeing this Shepard
more than our Mass Effect 2 Shepard we
don't really do that in one let's fit
casual though - we're gonna do that
right oh yeah because he looks no I mean
that is the classic I'd say either the
hoodie or like the hoodie though yeah
kind of like the hoodie I wore the
hoodie when I played casual Shepard what
about like leather jacket Shepard I
don't know leather jackets are cool but
I guess people who think they're cool
were though they thinks he's cool yeah
like some people pull awful of the
jacket others don't
he doesn't look like the kind of guy
that pulls off a jacket but yeah that's
pretty goddamn stupid
I remember getting that pre-order
bonuses like really why the do I want
that all of those suck I've never liked
any of the customers well the Dragon Age
was kind you cannot cover his beautiful
face alright now we have to keep that up
we're not really much in the way let's
just get to the materials that's the
important part there we go it looks like
a cartoon character perfect awesome now
that now little one so what are we doing
we script a little bit we skipped a
paladin's moon she didn't matter anyway
because Garris is already dead so who
cares oh yeah who replaced them just
some random no there's just no one there
there's like a cutscene where Garrett's
would show up just nothing happens they
have a line where they're like man what
would garrison do if he was here and
then they'd say something oh rest in
peace cares
commander the Silurian dollar trust and
Croghan clan chief are ready to come
aboard ooh time to ruin some
relationships here and hope this doesn't
start another war you know I hope it
starts another war this guy you know
he's ahe's a politicking he's a deal
maker with a face like that why the [ __ ]
did you change look at him he's outfit
yeah did we we did not give him
permission to do that oh man yes - he
can't just do it going in a leather
jacket cuz he looks better now fix your
face next time I really said something
that Rex looks more attractive than our
Shepherd nose little Rex is pretty hot
let's be honest I'm sure for the
genophage damn solutely not the
genophage is non-negotiable I don't care
I need a banana Pal oven is burning
right now earth is burning right now if
it takes a cure to submit this alliance
then that's what I'm doing he's right
the hard truth is we don't have a choice
give Rex what he wants or none of us
will survive long enough to know who was
right or wrong alright here's our
three-person squad and ah boy who do you
want to bring we don't have a lot of
options who don't we want to bring
that's the actual question I should ask
yes okay then we've we've made that
decision
this is the Silurian homeworld
we're headed to they aren't used to
seeing croaking here's a bummer that
three is the first game where you
finally get to see all of the home
worlds of every alien race and they're
all burning I know right a word they say
if they start backtracking the angry
Croghan active isn't hurt who said
anything about acting just try to keep
it further are you going to lecture me
on restraint Shepard what are you
talking about
I found out you had access to Malins
data
oh [ __ ] the plot thickens our
consequences come back to us if you have
Javik here there's some good dialogue
we're here just like this is my is my
Peruvian and they're all just like what
no no what I can't believe that was cut
from there that was DLC do not believe
that dude that's it was like deal see
right away it was day 1 dlc that is
maybe one of the most egregious examples
of day 1 dlc o subsetting anyway they
tried to spin it to like oh it's just a
little bonus like nah man he was like
yeah major component applause far as I
was concerned Shepard excellent timing
good to have you here
Morton Morgan is so funny so
uncharacteristic of our Shepard Morton
would help the female program get
information to plan heard not encourage
political pressure to every female you
must be Rexes inside source
yes can explain later security warnings
not normally need to get off oil for
sake of Croghan what do you think the
drawback is of missing one of your ear
thingies as a Silurian oh like what are
those do yeah what do they do well it
cuz it looks like his ears over there i
sticking it that's his ear hole right
yeah he has an ear hole
I need the Cure to win ah no no that's a
good question don't have a get me to
hurry
like what purpose does it serve to serve
a purpose Hey
or if it does I don't know yeah it
doesn't seem to impair his brain
function at all dad he's such a good
character one of the best please be
careful
propene slow to trust i'm commander
shepard alliance navy goddess what she's
been through
burden Rex and I are here to take you
home
her bark and chip it's not key to a
truce between the Krogan and turians
real laying it out there to you
release the female we're leaving I can't
protocol states during lockdown no
specimen dare more denoted now please
release Croghan need to monitor plotted
affairs warranty procedures meet us at
next checkpoint Shepherd likely server a
supposition of a cure
I'm here just let me do the thing okay
of course gotta hit the power relay it's
one of these tube things that seem to be
the universal control system in the Mass
Effect universe it does kind of I do
have that for everything don't they I
think she ducked you see those reflexes
down Wow
there we go dead that worked you think
he's dead he's dead he's probably dead
oh this Shepherd needs a Twitter account
I have a friend he's actually been
watching this series and his last name
was Shepherd really and yeah and that
work me my other friend Matt we'd all
like Shepherd shepherd yes I say it a
lot and I he needs a Twitter account
name we're making the Twitter yeah he's
actually he's also like a huge mass spec
fan like he's ahe's a crazy by RFM
what should the twitter handle be for
this just baldwin underscore scheppers
sure what even get had to eat on that I
don't know count with a good tweet what
am i interested in add your interest
killing my squealing my squad
why servers here what do you want
I gotta run the bathroom real quick back
oh thank you pit going
[Music]
how long what I miss nothing actually
was in a single voice decision or really
had just played again we have to pick
one of these missions to do do we want
to help the Krogan team or do we want to
assist the turians with the bomb uh oh
yeah uh maybe do two turns first okay
yeah I think you'll have to do one oh so
let's hop the Train it's because we want
to scrub for X if we're just knocking
out wrecks out all right
that's taken care of Tudor account is up
baldwin underscore shepard you can't
miss some with that mug got it this
sounds bad
let's move
almost got it Berenice dams quite the
explosion I wonder what's in its body to
make an explosion like that like a nuke
goes often I know maybe they're just
filled with mini nukes from fallout boom
that is a huge explosion the reapers did
not do a good job of making that if they
just loaded its inside with explosives
probably red barrels Commander Shepard
my men and I are in your eye they all
hate him Thank You leader what happened
here it screwed up Stand Down soldier
making hard decisions of dealing with
the consequences
that's what being a leader is about
you're right commander our missions
still a failure when we've stabilized
the injured we'll head back to the fleet
you're abandoning your mission
we're down over 30 men it'd be suicide
what exactly did you come here to do
there's a bomb on the planet we were
sent to defuse it a bomb
how big enormous Cerberus has it
lieutenant if Cerberus has that bomb
yeah you shouldn't just kind of bail on
that one sacrifice is what we signed on
for they know that and so should you
my men have lost hope commander even if
I wanted to god his his armor looks so
dumb usually though he just looks so
dumb he kinda reminds you Christmas
though with that red hair and green it's
okay it's like a Christmas tree with a
widow with an ugly face ornament on top
this isn't about your fears and
grievances fears
we're only afraid of the next messed-up
order you give irrelevant
court-martialled death and dishonor
awaits anyone who walks at his duty
we artery we finished what we came here
to do or we die trying
Shepard test verified results promising
can synthesize for universal program
immunity good but you can put your knife
away the cures ready no still need
transmission better cure useless unless
given to entire species you infected
them with the disease easy enough is the
Cure that different know keeping
modality similar when possible easiest
way to develop your rapidly groundwater
no too slow voluntary inoculation risky
population too scattered for airborne
unless wait yes the shroud constant
global dispersion of air particles built
by salarians to repair atmospheric
tachanka also use by torian's we used it
to secretly spread the genophage virus
it ended the krogan rebellions I'd be
careful who you tell that to that was
clever you're going to infect an entire
population that's the way to do it
unless your population yes yes just
desiring erect original genophage
strains still in storage at shroud
facility can use it as transmission
vector then you shroud to blanket to
chakra with cure you clever little pie
Jack that's our best shot right there
then finish your preparations and be
ready to go Morden we can provide you
our very best scientists to build the
crucible and the full support of our
fleets if I sabotage the cure
think about it commander the choice is
yours
Rex are you sure you're ready for this
after your procedure one more word and
somebody gets tossed out of the shovel
now I've ordered the clans to assemble
at the hollows it's our sacred meeting
ground we'll land there and take an
armored convoy against the Reaper this
will be the defining moment of Croghan
history commander you seem troubled
there's just a lot of maligned
I want this to go well happy yeah we
like didn't talk to her at all this [ __ ]
nope
my all of the the context and we just
did all of it I can't believe you can
play like it's crazy to me that you
could just play these games and skip a
lot of dialogue like I understand not
want to click on every nitty gritty
option but like you would at least want
to talk to these people yeah they'll
sing songs about this someday
well six apart we soaked our soil
we have to get to the shrap the
airstrike is on its way
female saved shepherd recommend haste
Hellerman vital signs troubling
what's a Silurian multiple Croghan
problematic there's no time for this
whatever grudge you have against
salarians ends right now
as long as the nonfluent is head time
for some payback the Silurian is with me
narcho should have also we say here let
old wounds fester has cloven have always
done or you can fight the enemy you were
born to destroy and win a new controller
yeah I choose to fight who will join me
I don't want to regret hearing genophage
you lying son of a [ __ ] Shepard now
it's my turn to give a speech you
two-faced [ __ ] to the music and
everything why you just lie well we have
a chance to redeem ourselves here yeah
then they give you multiple options too
like yeah you get two or three two for
sure copy that oh man we're on our way
trying to make up lost time Shepard I'll
revisit the only club that you want to
be banned for the genophage Rex
you'll have to placate them somehow
there's that look in your eye again
commander what's troubling you
just thinking about Earth really choked
up about it you liar what is that oh
yeah I guess we wouldn't know because we
never did that side quest yeah
I'd say we've seen this before this is
unexpected
my scans confirm the presence of rack 9
DNA recti but how you killed their queen
on no Varia interesting that they add
dialogue mute yeah for like if you
didn't do that quest rumors you just
skip through we've got rachni here it's
an impressive game the right writing
this must have been a nightmare oh
you're not a nightmare but like a great
keeping track of it all right yeah all
the different audio like just yeah I
mean like how do you think of that like
you're playing it's like oh wait a
second someone may have not done the
mission where you've seen the rack and I
Shepard should probably say something
like what is that because because
otherwise when rack and I show up later
in combat yeah I always wanted a
telltale style cop procedural game
starring Garris illnesses that'd be
pretty cool that was that was my
everyone's like what Mass Effect game
you want like that want that and like
the end of the game is like him being
lifer gotta we got a case tree you got
to check out sarin sarin Oh Jerry have
you never seen killing Morton nope oh
man I've seen it I mean maybe we
wouldn't the game first came out I like
googled some of that stuff but I don't
pretty sure I have it whoa
you guys shouldn't watch you don't want
me to kill you to do you well actually
and that's so cool yeah
imagine fighting a reaper controlled
thresher mom oh wow Abby be scary I mean
yeah that would be scary
nothing is huge it is
oh man
oh boy here it is Mort is the cure rate
yes loaded for dispersal in two minutes
but e dead what happened
stress sampling too intense oh yeah
chorus points oh yeah okay if you
refused her decision a lot of people
died today Morton there's nothing we can
do female with stabilizing force program
will help Rex rally more fans in support
yeah control room at top of Shot Tower
let's take elevators you're going up
there yes readings that laughs together
temperature malfunction could affect
your viability need to adjust settings
manual
it's too dangerous Borden we need to get
out of here no temperature variance
could destroy cure time running out have
to go up Morton
you're not going up not consider for my
safety concerned I might discover
something sabotage but whose why shared
that desperate for so Larry made for
that afraid of program
every time we've talked about this
before you've defended the genophage
hell you destroy baylin's data how can
you change your mind now I made a
mistake I made a mistake focused on big
picture big picture made of little
pictures too many barriers yes
need to go running out of time they give
you so many options to back out of this
I know
Morten walk away can't do that Shepard I
don't have a choice here matter the
choice is yours the choice is yours
I don't have a choice here walk away or
I will fire not your decision not your
work not your jerk
someone else might have gotten it wrong
no time to argue George's personal
dividend must counteract sabotage stop
me if you must
oh my face oh well I don't feel good
about that
good about that the gun or maybe he just
doesn't care take you the gun
[Music]
what kind of monster would do this on
purpose yes yeah
[Music]
yet this is awful not ready
goddamn that's rough man yeah
[Music]
dang was the roughest death yet I think
that's maybe tally tally might be more
rough that well this is gonna be pretty
bad we've seen tallies I have Alex and
Elias how he's really rough
damn goddamn
unless you have a hand in it
Malins our search might have sir God
keep bringing that lever no I won't hold
a grudge Shepard you've proven you're
still a friend Christ too bad about
Gordon though ha ha ha why y-you mean up
on the tower courageous little pie jack
a thousand years from now will probably
be singing songs about it very nice tell
the Primark I'll be deploying troops to
pehlivan immediately and when you're
ready to kick the Reapers off earth you
let me know the krogan are back in
business and that is episode 4 of the
saddest party on the Citadel kind of
ended on a downer this one downer but a
I mean this was the plan Jake yeah it
had to happen but if you're enjoying
this series kind of like a car accident
you just like can't look away even
though you know you shouldn't be
watching then be sure to subscribe and
check out our other content we do have a
lot of Mass Effect stuff up right now
including the review and our two-part
documentary series about the making of
Andromeda and by the way we are
recording this outro post when the
original episode was supposed to go up
we apologize to you everyone for not
having the episode up when we wanted to
we had some weird technical issues but
the saddest party will carry on see you
guys
[Music]